happiness as an emotion is one on a
spectrum of many it is of course our
favorite emotion though and we dedicate
our entire lives trying to isolate it
but even if we could control the
conditions of life to solely produce
happiness we should not want to without
negative emotions we would never know
what feels positive we do not want the
emotion of happiness to be permanent
because without binary contrast there is
no distinction between emotions and
therefore there becomes none what we
need is a different kind of happiness
happiness that comes from the
appreciation of the idea that we are
able to feel and experience the entire
spectrum of life and emotion we must not
confuse attempting to achieve a sense of
wonder and stimulation in life with
attempting to achieve the emotion of
happiness it is good to feel the emotion
happiness and we should try our best to
do so as much as possible but when we
chase the idea that this happiness can
be a ceaseless and constant state of
being we remain in a never-ending
pursuit attempting to blockade the ebb
and flow of life but of course this is
impossible the flow of life is far too
strong and powerful too damn there are
too many moving parts for everything to
always work in favor of just one person
including you
you must instead be appreciating that
you are not always happy and that life
thinks you're worthy of experiencing the
incredible array of emotions things
won't always be good and things won't
always be bad but at least they will
always be deep down we fear a life of
complete certainty and happiness if our
lives were free from all problems our
only remaining problem will be not
having anything a sense of purpose would
dissolve we would stand still in a world
that is in constant motion in order to
be a part of the life around us we must
move with it and accept the flow of ups
and downs you must be like a garden out
of which the entire spectrum of emotions
can grow as the seasons and conditions
of life change certain plants will bloom
while others will die but as the cycle
rotates your garden will remain rich
sustainable and full of life ironically
by maintaining an appreciation for the
whole spectrum of emotions happiness
will appear more often your life and you
will get what you really wanted in the
first place
[Music]
you